as we've done in a couple of other
videos Shawn we're gonna talk about
those links between physics and
computing and again we're back to the
ultimate limits of computation and the
book I have in front of me is a book
that has caused a massive amount of
consternation over the last few decades
it's by a guy called character ex-law
now the reason it's perhaps of interest
to computerphile audience it's 1992 most
outstanding computer science book
well what Drexler is talking about
interaction is a very polarizing figure
is can we do computing with individual
atoms can we think of instead of
compiling code could we compile a matter
or to put it in another way though
Drexler didn't put it in these terms but
could we do 3d printing with individual
atoms could we use those those are very
you know very smallest building block
and if we could that's a remarkable
technology that means we you know
because are some of the more extreme
proponents of Drexler's vision had in
mind we could for example envision some
technology which is effectively looks
like a microwave we'd go outside we'd
get some grass
we'd come we'd put it into our thing
that looks like a microwave oven we
press a button under ding 30 seconds
later our eye pops a snake this is like
replicators and stuff it's exactly like
Star Trek replicators one pan fried
catfish we talked about this on one of
the previous videos that you guys have
manipulated atoms and made a switch
without yes these sorts of basic
building blocks are being pushed around
at the minute they are and but Drexler's
vision is much more - grander than now -
actually claims that we should be able
to take any lump of matter and convert
it not quite into any other lump of
matter but certainly to break those
chemical bonds down and form a structure
to a predefined blueprint importantly
he's not saying that we have to you know
but we're gonna disobey the laws of
physics it's not saying that we're
operating in some strange parallel
universe with the normal laws of physics
don't work but he is for example talking
about systems like diamond he's
a lot of time with diamond which is a
strongly bonded substance
you know diamond is fairly hard tight
covalent bonds holding the atoms in
place and he makes the argument that we
should be able to under those
circumstances if we can control the
bonding on a single chemical bond by a
single chemical bond basis the atoms
will stay in place and we shall be able
to build up different structures so he
focused a lot of its time on diamond um
I can show you a short video shown okay
so we have this microwave object and on
the side here with these canisters what
we have a very simple food stocks or
very simple stock that's that's put in
so simple molecules like co2 water co
methane perhaps molecules that can be
broken down into component atoms and
then built up into something bigger and
just how much bigger we'll see in a
second and cooling etc quite how it all
works we don't know this is science
fiction but like the best science
fiction it makes you think is this
possible could we manipulate matter like
this out there in computer file and
think about this does this disobey any
the laws of physics and you know drugs
has been widely castigated perhaps
unfairly
I think certainly unfairly in some cases
because these are these are grand ideas
grand visions are a worth worth
exploring
are we anywhere near this no we're
nowhere near this but you can see what's
happening now is with zooming in and now
we're down to the ten nanometer levels
so just to give you an idea in atoms a
few there's a fraction of a nanometer
across 0.3 of a nanometer so once or 10
nanometers we're talking about six three
hundred out something like that across
so here's these molecules streaming in
so in this case it's c2 here - and
what's happening is they're being fed
through moving across it looks very much
like the type of machinery were on meals
and factories were used to in the
macroscopic world except it's all shrunk
down each one of these single spheres is
a single atom and what's happening is
you're getting atom atom transfer you're
breaking these molecules down you can
see what's happening now transferring
them across to these tips these probes
this is where scanning probe microscopy
is together like myself get very very
interested in that we have a sharp probe
we bring it in close to a surface move
it back and forth this probe is
atomically sharp so it allows us to see
single out
and single molecules and manipulate
single atoms and single molecules so
some scanning probe microscopes at least
look at this and think world parts of
that we can do problem is very very
small parts of it we can take moving the
video on that's scrolled through various
different elements what happens later on
is we have different blocks that are
transferred across different elements
quite how any of this works we don't
know where does it get its energy source
we don't know and out at the end pops a
laptop the argument being that what's
happened is that those very simple
molecules at the start by building them
up manipulating the very individual
atoms we've compiled matter into this
final final form so this video the you
said this is science fiction this isn't
science fiction as far as we have
written this is Drexler Drexler believes
this is this is something that that
would be possible in the future many of
us have many issues surfaces in
particular a particular issue in terms
of it looks very simple that we'll just
get some blocks and we snap them
together in reality surface physics is
incredible surface chemistry is
incredibly incredibly challenging to
surmount but the again the ideas here
are fascinating it really is
could we could we do this even at the
level of you know how would we get a
power source here for that little sorter
for the molecules forget about a whole
laptop let's let's reduce this all the
way down can we do information
processing with single atoms or single
molecules or groups of atoms or groups
of molecules can we translate all that
complexity down and think can we on the
basis of individual atoms and molecules
do information processing and yes we've
done that the nanoscience community has
done that I suspect not many computer
file and are familiar with this it's a
beautiful beautiful piece of work and
stunningly elegant piece of work from
Donna gloss groups for Dawn's retired
now but his group at IBM Almaden was
search lads was responsible for a lot of
the pioneering work in nanoscience
indeed eggless group is responsible for
manipulating atoms for the very first
time and what they spelt out was the IBM
logo
this is beyond elegant they
computing information processing they've
set up logic gates with molecules and
they've done it in a really fascinating
way because they've effectively used a
domino effect in terms of how molecules
interact with each other to transfer
information from inputs to output and
they're done on the basis of Co carbon
monoxide very very small quantities you
don't have to worry about any poisoning
or nothin like that
altering an ultra-high vacuum all sort
very very low temperatures four degrees
above absolute zero
so it's not toxic at all but they put
them down on a copper surface and when
the co molecules go down on a copper
surface they absorb in a number of
different states they absorb like this
where it forms this little dark patch
the red dot represents a co molecule or
it forms this type of structure where
the two molecules are beside each other
which is a dimer to see all molecules
together or it forms this structure
which is a trimer three molecules
together how do they image this how do
they see the individual molecules well
it comes back to that scanning probe
technology sharra probe close the
surface move back and forth and if the
probe is atomically sharp you can see
individual atoms or molecules so what
they do is they manipulate the seal
molecules here's a co molecule so you
can operate in a mode where you scan or
you re something very straightforward
you push the probe towards the surface
and you do that and you move it across
the surface so you can manipulate an
image just by moving the height of the
probe above the surface so what they do
is they set up these arrangements they
set up dimers dime out dime or dime or
Domo Domo then what they do is they
bring in another molecule this one with
the green arrow bring it closer and what
that does is it triggers see the red
dots are the positions and Co it
triggers this cascade process whereby
they all rearrange just like a set of
dominoes they're not falling the
molecules are rearranging themselves
it's not like the falling over but
they're re arranging themselves now
that's clever enough that's really
clever and although this is 2002
although it's 16 years ago it's still
like an incredible nominal paper just
our reversible process that no
because dominoes aren't easy no so what
what we're not talking about is so this
is this is the difference between
fundamental science and technological
application first all you know if we
were
to take this type of approach I think
we're gonna be hard-pressed to sell it
to anyone because most people are not
going to want to top the computer up
with liquid helium that's the first
thing
pretty pretty complicated and irritating
to keep an ultra-high vacuum going more
over the bandwidth is about point one or
maybe point zero one of her Hertz
because you have to set this entire
system up and then set it off it's not
reversible there are other systems for
which it is reversible but not this but
this is this is exploring the limits
what they do here is they develop
different gates by setting up different
arrangements of molecules so here's one
example of a NAND gate
whereby we've got input X and input Y
here and so by by bringing in molecules
either by causing a cascade here or
causing a cascade here or causing a
cascade at both points then the output
here will change so basically here if we
bring a molecule in here to settle one
here but there's a zero here there's no
molecule here then what happens is
there's no change the iput remains
however and similarly the opposite way
however in this case if you bring in a
tripping molecule here and a tripping
molecule here or control molecule here
then what happens is there is a big
change and you can read that as a change
in the output so what we have is a logic
gate made out of molecules which is is
made out of this molecular cascade okay
at work operates incredibly slowly okay
it's under extreme conditions but as a
piece of elegant science it's phenomenal
why do they need these incredibly low
temperatures why do they need to be at 4
degrees above absolute zero the problem
is with this system with molecules on
metal surfaces what happens is if you
warm the temperature up even slightly by
10 20 30 degrees something like that
then thermal motion kicks in and the
molecules also wander across the surface
so these beautifully engineered
structures you've made will fall apart
just to the tooter diffusion effectively
Brownian motion it's not quite thrown in
motion but the same type of thing so
what you need to do is find systems
whereby this type of diffusion doesn't
kick in and actually Drexler had it
right
so what you need to think about is
covalently bonded system
with the bonds of stronger instead of
weak bonds between the molecules and the
surface which is actually quite good
because it allows you to do this release
to slide things around with ease but the
problem is then in terms of trying to
exploit that in any type of realizable
technology it's really difficult so you
need something where the bonds are quite
strong and where you can raise the
temperature without things hopping
around and they've been major efforts
over the last few years to do this with
silicon and in fact we're now at the
point where this is Michele Symons group
in University New South Wales so a
number of groups working on this
Michele's group in University New South
Wales bob wykel's group in University of
Alberta does Christians watching
children sorry Christian you know I
always get the pronunciation wrong CNRS
who's led to lose who's led a big effort
on this doors
Stephen Scofield group in University
College London we've dabbled a bit as
well not quite at the level of those
other groups we've dabbled a little bit
in this in terms of really manipulating
at the single-bond level Michelle's
group however has made an important leap
whereby they've taken this type of
atomic scale engineering and they made a
transistor out of it this this paper
really needs its colours to the mast a
single atom transistor and what they do
is they pattern a silicon surface so we
did a video for sixty symbols a number
of years ago which describes just how
this works but basically you take a
silicon surface you crack it open and
you form two surfaces the atoms here and
the atoms here are really uncomfortable
they're no longer in their nice
environment where they were bonded to
the neighbors atoms are very gregarious
they like to bond so when you split them
open when you split that that crystal
open exposed to surfaces it's a very
high energy state the atoms don't like
to be in that state so what you can do
is you can pass away at that surface so
you can make it less reactive by adding
other atoms to it so the bonds are tied
up and a really good one is hydrogen so
you put silicon so you take the silicon
crystal in vacuum the surface and you
bombard it with hydrogen and what you
can do is you can sit above an
individual hydrogen atom bombard it with
electrons and remove one
one single hydrogen atom so you've got
one chemical bond and again to be fair
to Drexler this is the type of thing he
was talking about quite some time ago
then what you can do and this is what
Michelle's group has done is that that
one dangling bond now you got that one
bond that's and it's literally called
dangling bond that's what we will call
it so you've got this inert surface with
this one dangling bond then what happens
if you put all the molecules down in
this case they've they've put a
phosphorous containing complement down
is that it would bond in just at that
point and that means you can put down a
single phosphorous out him at that point
and that's what they've done and
phosphorous is what's called a dopant in
silicon but basically you add impurities
to control the electronic properties of
silicon and that's how practice every
single electronic device and every
single semiconductor device relies on
the properties of doping in this case
we're down to the limit of doping with a
single atom and that's what they've
based this this single atom transistor
on is they've managed to access and
address that single atom to form a
single arm transistor so that's really
quite phenomenal interesting the one
thing we were missing okay you could
create this this diamond bond but really
you need to be able to correct it and to
reverse it and to be able to ever
correct for one thing it's taken a long
time to go it's like a 90s when it was
shown that you could D you remove the
hydrogen taking a long time to get
enough control over the probe to be able
to just connect the probe or push the
probe into the surface and transfer that
single hydrogen atom to heal out that
defect so here's the defect that one
single bond and as you can see hits
functionalized tip then they bring it in
and they connect with directly that
dangling bond so tip comes in dangling
bond tip and at the end of the tip
there's a single hydrogen atom and it
transfers and you heal it up so we're
now at the point where we can make these
structures make these dangling bond
features but also repair them which
means that when it comes to generating
logic gates in terms of making
structures whereby we can have arrays of
these dangling bond features that
communicate with each other not in the
same not quite the same as the molecular
cascades but the same idea well perhaps
we transfer instead of a physical
transfer of maliki
we have a transfer of electrons then we
really are processing at the atomic
limit we've got a long way to go before
we get back to Drexler's nanosystems a
long long way to go but then the next
idea is well can we actually we've got
information processing at the single a
time limit were processing matter at the
single atom limit how far can we push
this one three two one three there we
are back up nice five one three about
time because by narrowing down that time
we broaden out the energy associated
with it with the operation which sets a
fundamental limit because a narrow
narrow narrow narrow we get that the
broader